good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight so if you're the White
House Press Secretary and thank God
you're not but if you were you would
have two tasks every day you got to
learn the president's views on what's
happening in the world so you can repeat
them and then you've got to try to
remember the names of those weird
looking people sitting in the folding
chairs in the briefing room so it's not
an easy job but it's not a very
rewarding one either you're not making
policy you're not making decisions
you're repeating the party line under
normal circumstances it takes a lot more
creativity to say sell lipstick for
L'Oreal than it does to be White House
Press Secretary they're all worn out by
the end except under Joe Biden it's a
totally different job under Joe Biden
the rules have changed if your Joe
Biden's press secretary you've got to be
able to think on the Fly because your
boss can't
so every time Biden goes outside you're
going to be called upon to translate
what he said or explain what he really
meant assuming for the sake of argument
that he really meant anything at all I
know you're frustrated Biden said today
for example I can taste it
what does frustration taste like an
earthy slightly anxious blend of bacon
notes mango and raspberry with an
undertone of Saddle leather maybe Joe
Biden didn't say
the White House Press Secretary would
know that's her job or to name another
example which United States senators
represent the State of Florida and which
represent the state of Wisconsin which
is not near Florida
well the press secretary would have to
know that too in case Biden screws it up
as of course he just did today Etc
so it's not an easy gig and it's a
particularly tough job when the topics
are serious like nuclear war
a few weeks ago Joe Biden pledged to
overthrow the government of Russia which
is fully capable of waging nuclear war
possessing as it does at least 6 000
nuclear warheads that's not a small
thing starting a global conflagration
and ending human life on the planet
so it fell to the press secretary to
clean it up we are not advocating for
killing the leader of a foreign country
or regime change Jen saki explained
despite the fact that Joe Biden had just
advocated for regime change in Russia
so it's a lot of power how did somebody
like jensaki someone so demonstrably
talentless a humorless gender Studies
major from Greenwich how did this person
get this much Authority in our
government
good question nowadays just comes with
the job of press secretary just hours
ago saki explained that federal law no
longer applies to mobs of Biden voters
they get to intimidate all the Supreme
Court justices they want as long as
they're on the right side of abortion
and we're quoting now we certainly
continue to encourage protests outside
judges home she said and in so saying
reversed hundreds of years of policy and
tradition and took yet another blow
against civilization and decency she
could do that because she's the press
secretary
she's gen saki or was next week she's
headed to MSNBC for a new life as a
cable news contributor we Sherlock of
course good luck Jen saki but in the
meantime you've got to wonder who's
going to replace her who could replace
her is anyone qualified is there another
person in this country as shallow nasty
and partisan as jensaki is well there is
her name is Karine Jean-Pierre
listen to gen sake Jen saki describe
Karine Jean-Pierre
first as you all know she will be the
first black woman of the first out lgbtq
plus person to serve in this role the
first black woman an out gay person to
speak for the president becoming the
first black woman and lgbtq person the
first black woman first openly gay
person the first black woman the first
openly gay person the first black person
first openly gay person becoming the
first black person and first openly
lgbtq person to serve as White House
Press Secretary well you heard it from
jensaki she's going to be the first
quote out lgbtq plus person to be White
House Press Secretary and thank God
but before you light a candle and begin
tonight's celebrations a quick question
what does lgbtq plus mean hey jensaki
let us know if you have a minute explain
every letter in that acronym and
specifically what it signifies well wait
don't hold your breath she's not going
to do it because like everybody else
uses that phrase jensaki literally has
no idea no clue at all what it means
it's one of those terms you're not
supposed to Define one day to start
using an lgbtq plus and anyone who asks
what it means is immediately presumed to
be in the out group
so it's not actually a word words are
meant to signify meaning and communicate
it to other people no it's not that at
all it's a litmus test and you could
fail oh you don't know what lgbtq plus
means keep an eye on that person hates
gays
but whatever don't ask questions
Korean Jean-Pierre is our first out
lgbtq plus White House Press Secretary
and that's all you need to know it's a
good thing shut up and celebrate that's
why she got the job she's in the right
group and to the bite Administration
which thinks exclusively in terms of
groups and never in terms of individuals
because individuals are messy and
inconvenient the group is all that
matters this is exactly how they pick
Supreme Court Justices or vice
presidents or members of the Federal
Reserve board and now the all-important
press secretary gig has gone to someone
on the basis of group it's really simple
show us your picture and we'll tell you
if you're qualified for the job
and in many ways Kareem Jean-Pierre is
perfect for the job not only is she a
member of the out lgbtq plus Community
she is also critically the product of a
private school and an Ivy League college
and yet still oppressed somehow she is
furious at America despite her ample
privilege and enraged by its racist
systems of Oppression and she's happy to
tell you about it here she is
when he got elected I think people
thought we were in a post-racial uh
America and we were not I think what we
learned is that racism was very much
real and still very much around and I
and the obstruction that he saw the um
uh this the horrible racist rhetoric of
uh of having a black family in the White
House was very clear that you felt the
hate and you saw the hate I just think
that America has a a really Pro a big
problem with race and it's very real
yeah they keep electing Obama and
promoting me despite the fact I have no
qualifications for the job lesson it's a
racist country
now there's a word for this kind of a
clever term it's called cry bullying
right stop hitting me they say as they
punch you in the face why do they do
well they do it because it works you
whine about racism and you get into the
best schools you get promoted and
eventually you run the federal
government and your presence atop the
food chain is nothing if not evidence
that the country is still racist it has
to be or you can't justify your job
kind of an amazing scam people like
Kareen Jean-Pierre have going she's
perfected it she used to work for MSNBC
she knows the script cold
here she is in 2020 yelling some more
about racism now if you imagine that
covid came from a lab in Wuhan which by
the way is true then according to Karine
Jean-Pierre you're not a person trying
to get to the truth no
can you guess what you are you're racist
the easy pivot is race is ethnicity you
say it's a foreign virus I've noticed
people tweeting Chinese coronavirus
that's what Tucker Carlson said right
yeah and you look at Fox News Fox News
was racist before coronavirus they are
races during the coronavirus Fox News
will be racist after the coronavirus so
there is nothing new here
so criticizing the Chinese government
the most powerful organization in the
world
is racist of course criticizing the
powerful is always racist America itself
is racist
talking about covet is racist what isn't
racist well we check Karine
jean-pierre's Twitter feed to find out
what isn't racist couldn't find much but
we did find a very long list of things
that are here is a non-exhaustive sample
that we compiled of racist people and
things according to Joe Biden's News
Press Secretary John cornyn is racist
Joe Arpaio is racist border walls
needless to say a racist Roseanne Barr
for some reason is racist the name
Pocahontas is racist despite the fact it
was an actual American Indian's real
name whatever it's racist Mike Huckabee
may seem nice but he's racist federal
government shutdowns don't seem like
they have anything to do with race oh
they're racist too Donald Trump racist
that's a no-brainer you knew that Jeff
session also racist brexit
again not connected to race doesn't mean
it's not racist it is according to Karin
Jean-Pierre
Ed Gillespie former Senate candidate in
Virginia racist thank God he didn't win
Ron DeSantis did win in Florida and
that's bad news because guess what he is
racist Steve Bannon racist Sebastian
Gorka racist and you know who's most
racist of all Republicans who criticize
Ralph Northam for wearing blackface in a
clan outfit you're racist racist if you
notice racism as long as the racist is a
Democrat
so awesome give that girl a big job
now you may be rolling your eyes because
you've heard all of this a million times
before ice cream and Shakespeare are
racist
but think about it for a second this is
the person the bite Administration hired
to tell the rest of us what Joe Biden
really means when he says for example
he's going to kill Vladimir Putin
how long until this person calls Putin a
racist
she probably already has how's that
going to turn out in the middle of a war
we might not have to wait long to find
out here's yet another incredibly racist
thing according to America's new Press
Secretary of course it is voter
identification laws now you will find
voter ID laws in every country on the
planet including in Africa but that
doesn't make them any less racist
and in order to get these voter
suppression laws besides gutting the
Voting Rights uh Voting Rights Act you
also got to get your people in there to
put these awful laws in place I'm so
glad that the Georgia issue is being
talked about almost every day now it's
getting national attention and it needs
to because what's happening is pure
racism
what spell racism that you honestly
didn't think we started the show saying
could you find someone more grading
Dumber more aggressive than jensaki
who's headed off to MSNBC next week and
the answer is oh yeah the bite
Administration
can find someone even worse that's their
job and just to restate voter ID laws
are racist according to Korean jop here
and if you have them you don't have a
fair election and we're quoting reminder
she wrote Brian Kemp stole the
gubernatorial election from Georgians
and Stacy Abram she wrote that in April
of 2020. she said something similar four
years before in 2016 we're quoting again
stolen emails stolen drone stolen drone
stolen election welcome to the world of
unprecedented Trump before even
pronouncing that correctly but take
three steps back
she used the term stolen election she
questioned voting integrity
she engaged in a baseless conspiracy
theory yes friend she did and you know
what that is we know because we read the
Atlantic magazine what you just heard is
a Brazen attack on our democracy it is a
disqualifying assault on our Norms our
sacred norms
it looks ladies and gentlemen like
Karine Jean-Pierre is an insurrectionist
a cue Enthusiast likely funded by
Vladimir Putin himself
that are called the doj and get her an
ankle monitor
just kidding we take it back we didn't
mean to question karee jump here
because that's the most racist thing of
all
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight